der russische gas hahn ist dicht und die
energiepreise gehen durch die decke die
ampel koalition hat ein weiteres
milliardenschweres entlastungs paket
verabschiedet die menschen aber blicken
sorgenvoll richtung winter gründe genug
für ein gespräch mit dem bundeskanzler
und damit begrüße ich sie sehr herzlich
zu unserem zdf sommerinterview mit olaf
scholz aus dem garten des
bundeskanzleramts
[Musik]
guten tag herr bundeskanzler runter und
herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview wir treffen uns im
garten des kanzleramtes ist ein ort den
ja kaum jemand kennt jetzt auch in der
form glaube ich lange nicht mehr geben
wird weil sie einen war erweiterungsbau
plan das kanzleramt ist ja eigentlich
schon jetzt die größte
regierungszentrale der welt und soll
noch mal verdoppelt wird ist es nicht
eigentlich an der zeit so einem projekt
jetzt zu stoppen das ist ein lange
geplante weiterführung des baus des
jetzigen kanzler amtes mit vielen platz
für diejenigen die hier arbeiten um die
heute auch viele gebäude verstreut sind
und ich glaube dass so eine lange
vorbereitete planung die jetzt sehr weit
fortgeschritten ist auch zu ende geführt
werden muss im übrigen ist das ja auch
verbunden mit einer ganz wichtigen
demokratischen geste dem das band des
bundes dass sich hier zwei mal über die
spree erstrecken soll das kann es nur
dann geben einmal quer zu all den
planungen die wir das nazi deutschland
hatte wenn es auch tatsächlich einmal
auf diese anderen seite das geplante
gebäude gibt und ich glaube es fast ein
bisschen zudem dass das kanzleramt jetzt
auch ausmacht ein helles gebäude ein
freundliches ein ort wo auch viele
bürger die bürger gern mal hinkommen
können und zu sehen wie hier gearbeitet
wird
aber sie haben jetzt die ganze nacht
fast über das entlastungspaket
verhandelt es geht um viel geld der
erweiterungsbau soll 640 millionen
kosten die zeiten haben sich verändert
noch mal die frage wäre es nicht
angemessen jetzt die reißleine zu ziehen
in deutschland muss investiert werden
das muss gebaut werden und ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass das was wir durch
all die maßnahmen die wir jetzt überall
in deutschland auch mit unseren
maßnahmen mit unserer aktivitäten
erreichen wollen gewährleisten wird das
weiter investiert das weitergebaut
wohnung fabriken büros straßen
eisenbahnlinien all das was wir brauchen
auch für unsere moderne infrastruktur
wenn es um die digitalisierung geht um
das was wir brauchen damit
elektromobilität funktioniert also
investieren ist jetzt das gebot der
stunde also genug themen ihr motto ist
you never walk alone ich darf sie zum
interview welche begleiten
[Musik]
da wurde es ganz klar wir führen dieses
gespräch am sonntagmittag kurz nachdem
sie das entlastungspaket 3 vorgestellt
haben der finanzminister soll im laufe
der verhandlung gestern gesagt haben da
rollt eine lawine auf uns zu lassen kann
man ja für gewöhnlich nicht aufhalten
auch nicht mit 65 milliarden können sie
den menschen zu sagen dass niemand unter
diese lawine der preise der kosten der
entwicklung gerät dann job bei der
wohnung bei der existenz ja das kann ich
dass wir kann ich ganz klar zu sagen
dass wir alles dafür tun werden dass das
nicht geschieht und wir haben ja auch
sehr früh angefangen denn das erste
problem ist ja dass wir möglicherweise
nicht genügend energie haben und deshalb
haben wir sehr früh entschieden dass wir
alles tun dass uns
keine große gefahr droht wenn zb so eine
meldung von allen gehört wird wie wir
sie gehört haben dass kein gast
mainz lieferte russland irgendwelche vor
während er hat mich zu liefern und das
haben wir aber angefangen schon dem
letzten jahr mit beginn des jetzigen
jahres und wir eröffnen anfang nächsten
jahres die ersten terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten um importieren zu
können wir haben gast eingespeichert wir
haben kohlekraft wieder zum laufen
gebracht werden möglich gemacht dass man
um dann auf gas zurückgreift in den
firmen auch wieder auf öl oder kohle
zurückgreifen kann das alles hilft dass
wir sicher durch diesen winter kommen
können und dann gibt es natürlich das
problem mit den preisen mit dem geld und
da kümmern wir uns jetzt darum dass das
auch etwas ist wo die preise von uns mit
allen möglichkeiten unter kontrolle
gebracht werden sollen aber wir
gleichzeitig dafür sorgen dass man auch
mithalten kann indem wir
entlastungsmaßnahmen für die bürger und
mosambik sie sagen wir kommen durch
diesen winter der
chef der union oder der cdu hat gewarnt
vor blacks können sie die ausschließen
wir haben alles dafür getan dass es
nicht dazu kommt und sind auch weiter
unterwegs um das zu ermöglichen ich habe
schon einige der maßnahmen berichtet zum
beispiel dass wir dafür gesorgt haben
dass wieder kohlekraftwerke die in
bereitschaft waren in den betrieb gehen
und strom produzieren damit vegas sparen
können so können sie es ausschließen ich
kann ihnen sagen dass alles was wir
getan haben dazu beiträgt dass das nach
allem menschlichen ermessen nicht
passiert und ich bin auch sehr sicher
dass uns das erspart bleiben eine der
maßnahmen die sie heute vorgestellt
haben ist die strompreis bremse für den
basis verbrauch ab wann gilt die denn
die betrifft ja dann im prinzip allen
und hilft allen und wie hoch ist diese
bremse das kommt jetzt so schnell wie
möglich wir müssen ja ganz viel eine
entscheidung treffen viele regelungen
durchsetzen damit das gelingt das erste
ist dass wir die zufalls gewinne die
jetzt auf dem strommarkt erzielt werden
abschöpfen dann gibt es ja ganz
versessen gehören mal die über
gewinnsteuern die eigentlich spd und
grüne wollten oder das andere ufer
zufalls gewinne über gewinner sind wenn
es gewinne die nichts mit dem zu tun
habe dass man eigentlich wirtschaftlich
tut werde seit jahren erfolgreich
windkraftanlagen betreibt solaranlagen
kohlekraftwerke betreiben kernkraftwerke
betreibt wasserkraft der produziert zu
viel geringeren kosten als diejenigen
die strom mit gas herstellen aber der
preis für strom wird gegenwärtig nach
dem europäischen markt design
bestimmt durch diese gasse frei
finanziert ist halt immer dagegen
argumentiert das sei rechtlich nicht
möglich und jetzt geht s es geht direkt
in dem strommarkt in dem wir so ähnlich
wie früher bei der umlage die wir für
die erneuerbaren energien erhoben und
seit dem sommer dieses jahres
abgeschafft haben das so machen dass wir
diese zu über gewinne zufalls gewinne
das was da über eine erlösobergrenze von
den unternehmen die nicht zu hohe
produktionskosten haben erwirtschaftet
wird abschöpfen und dann im nächsten
schritt an den bürgern und bürger
zurückgeben indem sie zb berechnung
netzentgelte
subventionieren die vielleicht durch die
decke schießen war alles teurer gewirkt
wird in der gegenwärtigen situation und
indem wir diese strompreis bremse für
den einzelnen haushalt schaffen das
heißt es wird ein nullsummenspiel das
heißt sie bekommen so viele rechte mit
so vielen milliarden durch diese zufalls
gewinne dass sie damit die strompreis
bremse finanzieren können ja das ist das
worum es uns geht und ich will hier
mich ein bisschen zurückhaltend das
konkrete prognosen betreffend wie viel
dabei erlöst wird weil das ja auch von
der entwicklung auf den strommärkten zu
abhängt die wehren unbegrenzt
vorhersehen können aber wenn dort solche
zufalls über gewinne im großen maßstab
anfang haben wir viele viele viele
milliarden um sie den bürgern und
bürgern zurückzugeben und das ist auch
genau sagen so kam aus dem anderen teil
der wirtschaft schon schrille warnungen
also das ist nicht nur um die entlastung
der bürger geht allein die chemie
industrie verzeichnet einen
produktionsrückgang von 10 prozent wie
groß ist denn ihre sorge um die
wirtschaft und in arbeitsplätze
ich mache mir die ganze zeit sorgen
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir das
hauptproblem lösen nämlich dass wir
nicht genügend energie nach deutschland
bekommen nicht genug kohle nicht genug
gas und das kann man nur gewährleisten
indem man ganz schnell die
infrastrukturen baut die deutschland
vielleicht hätte mit sicherheit 14 20
jahren anfangen sollen zu bauen aber die
wir jetzt in einem jahr errichten wollen
in anderthalb jahren damit wir sagen
können was auch immer passiert wir
können immer importiert morgen gibt es
in leipzig die erste sogenannte
montagsdemo
einigen tausend teilnehmern nur aber
selbst die arbeitsminister herr heil
warnt davor und sagt die stimmung sei
auf einem ganz sensiblen punkt wie
besorgt sind sie über die lage im land
ich mache mir vor allem erst mal die
sorgen der bürgerinnen und bürger das
sind auch meine und das hat nicht um
sich über den bürger gedanken machen wie
das weitergeht mit der stromrechnung wie
das weitergeht und der heizungs rechnung
mit dem dass sie für gas bezahlen müssen
wenn sie sich sorgen machen um den
betrieb wo sie arbeiten wenn der kleine
handwerksmeister die kleine
unternehmerin nicht weiß ob das alles
noch hinhaut mit den kosten für die
energie und dem was sie verkaufen
anbieten wollen und deshalb ist das
unsere ganz große aufgabe die
bedingungen dafür zu schaffen dass wir
durchkommen und da haben wir viel für
getan ich habe das eben schon
geschildert und das was wir im
wirtschaftliche finanzielle hilfe
leisten können auch damit unternehmen in
dieser situation unterstützung bekommen
das werden wir auch tun das ist auch
teil unseres programms damit haben wir
lange angefangen und das wollten wir
jetzt sehr aus damit das auch wirklich
funktioniert ich bin sicher dass
deutschland auch als demokratie durch
diese zeit kommt bei sind ein sehr
wirtschaftsstarkes land und wir sind das
ist mir wichtig ein sozialstaat und
beides zusammen ist wichtig aber müssen
sie nicht auf den menschen jetzt sagen
wir werden nie mehr in diesen günstigen
zustand vor dem angriffskrieg russlands
kommen
das wäre sogar
falsch wenn man die längere perspektive
in den blick nimmt denn das kann man
sagen mit jedem neuen offshore windpark
mit jeder windanlagen an land mit all
den solaranlagen mit viel biomasse mit
den ausbau unseres stromnetzes werden
wir unabhängiger wir wollen wir eine um
die mitte dieses jahrhundert 245
erfolgreiche industrienationen seien die
klimaneutrale wirtschaftet das ist
wichtig für das klima eben aber das
führt gleichzeitig dazu dass wir
unabhängiger werden von importen von
fossilen ressourcen aus anderen ländern
und dass wir auch an billigere
produktion haben wir sehen das ja gerade
jetzt und die stromproduktion aus
erneuerbaren quellen eigentlich sehr
billig ist und wir jetzt versuchen das
dann nicht extra gewinne gemacht werden
und deshalb ist das der weg und den
haben wir bestritten massiv auszubauen
den vielen gesetzen die wir jetzt auf
den weg gebracht haben und noch vielen
die kommen alle in diesem jahr und die
andere sache ist ja wenn wir
sehen wie die nachfrage ist auf dem
weltmarkt kohle gas und öl wenn wir
sehen wie viele sich auch wir und wie
wir um flüssiggas bemühen dann ist es
sicherlich so dass es nicht ganz so
billig sein wird diese fossile energie
zu importieren wie früher und darauf
müssen wir uns einstellen und müssen die
zeit durchstehen das können wir auch ist
das dann immer besser wird weil wir gar
nicht mehr auf diese importe angewiesen
sind sie haben jetzt gestern abend und
auch in der nacht ein großes entlastungs
paket verhandelt ist ein drittel schon
in folge bisher zeigen die zahlen die
umfragen dass die menschen mit der
arbeit der ampel auch ihre arbeit nichts
hier zufrieden sind andreas kienast hat
erst mal in 60 sekunden zusammen
zehn monate nach seinem amtsantritt
sinkt das ansehen von bundeskanzler
stolz auf die bisherigen tiefs punkte
noch nie war die bewertung seiner
leistung so schlecht die umfragen für
die regierung sehen nicht besser aus
obwohl scholz nach russlands überfall
den deutschen und den verbündeten eine
radikale neuausrichtung verspricht wir
erleben
zeitenwende gelingt es dem bundeskanzler
nie den eindruck zu zerstreuen dass
deutschland nur zögerlich hilft sogar
bremst auch die ampel flackert nach der
zusage niemanden mit den hohen
energiepreisen alleinzulassen you'll
never walk alone zerstreitet sich die
koalition über die gas umlage für
aufsehen sorgt dass der kanzler schweigt
als palästinenserpräsident abbas neben
ihm holocaust vorwürfe gegen israel
äußert aber auch der regierungs flug
ohne maske könnte dazu beigetragen haben
dass scholz ansehen auf den bisherigen
tiefs punkten ist herr bundeskanzler nur
noch jeder dritte ist mit ihrer arbeit
zufrieden 70 prozent mit der ampel
unzufrieden und kann man sagen die
zeiten sind einfach auch schwierig und
dennoch gibt es mitglieder ihrer
regierung robert habeck frau bär borg
die deutlich besser dastehen wie
erklären sie sich diesen unterschied es
sind wie sie sagen sehr schwierige
zeiten und da gibt es nur eine
handlungsmaxime man muss das richtige
tun in ernsten zeiten das haben die
beiden auch das haben wir getan und ich
habe ihm ein paar dinge genannt die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben und sie haben
ja gesehen dass wir jetzt sehr
geschlossen als regierung sehr
weitreichende entscheidungen getroffen
werden an dem tag wo wir das dritte
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
habe das war dass daran auch beteiligt
das dritte entlastungs paket auf den weg
gebracht haben und dafür gesorgt haben
dass das noch größer ausfällt als die
ersten beiden eine sehr notwendige an
sehr angemessene reaktion ich bin ganz
sicher dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
viele fragen haben auch an die politik
und zu den fragen zählt auch durchaus
für den einen oder anderen ob das alles
richtig ist was sie wir machen also es
gibt bürger mitbürger die sehr gute
ansichten haben im übrigen aber die
zweifel haben in der unterstützung der
ukraine die zweifel haben an den
funktionen die wir als eu gemacht die
ganze region finde ich richtig und
deshalb sage ich dass ich finde richtig
dass wir diese dinge tun aber ich
akzeptiere dass wir das diskutieren
müssen und deshalb kann immer nur den
maßstab sein dass wir für unsere politik
werden und die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen und dann würde ich ihn gerne
auch sagen dass ich schon weiß dass es
meine fans forderung ist dafür zu sorgen
dass wir entschiedene handlung machen
und dass wir sehr besonnen handeln und
ich ertrage dass das andere skeptisch
betrachten aber ich habe einen eid
geschworen und zu diesen alt werde ich
arbeiten tag und nacht da höre ich dann
eine unterschied zu anderen den sie
andeuten herr von notz der vize
fraktionschef der grünen hier durchaus
auch ein moderater mensch der hat sie
sehr deutlich kritisiert sagt man
zitieren die schlechte performance des
bundeskanzlers seine miesen umfragewerte
erinnerungslücken bei warburg und seine
verantwortung bei nordstream 2 robert
habeck hat sich dann sehr deutlich davon
abgesetzt und hat sich vor sie gestellt
lars klingbeil aber der spd chefs hat
robert habeck wiederum handwerkliche
fehler vorgeworfen haben sie ihnen auch
zurechtgewiesen
die regierung arbeitet sehr ordentlich
zusammen wir haben es gerade heute
wieder bewiesen ob wir werden das auch
weiter tun und ich habe als
bundeskanzler die aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass alle ministerinnen und
minister an ihrem platz das richtige tun
und ich bin überzeugt dass das auch der
fall ist wir haben ernste zeiten und da
muss man das tun was zu tun ist und das
werden wir auch und ich kann aber ihnen
versichern wir werden durch diese
ernsten zeiten durchkommen auch gerade
deshalb weil es um themen gibt die mir
wichtig sind wenn auch nicht immer
überall medial sehr diskutiert werden
für mich geht es darum dass die leute
die nicht so viel geld verdienen die
sich jeden tag anstrengen die ganz
ordentlich verdienen aber auch rechnen
müssen gut zurecht kommen und ich finde
schon dass es zu der welt in der wir
leben gehört dass man durchsetzt wenn es
kaum
öffentliche aufmerksamkeit genießt dass
es demnächst ein mindestlohn eine
erhöhung von 1 des mindestlohns auf 12
euro geben wird und dass davon sechs
millionen profitieren denn dafür habe
ich mich eingesetzt den hinweis an
kriegen weil habe ich auch gehört in dem
sie sich vor ihre minister gestellt hat
es gibt immer wieder kritik an ihrer an
ihren reaktionen beziehungsweise an
ihren nicht reaktionen sie sind wie man
weit zurückgeht in der elbphilharmonie
geblieben als auf der straße in hamburg
bei g20 der die demonstranten auf der
strasse tun sie haben auf see lenski im
bundestag nicht reagiert als er dort
seine ansprache hatte und sie haben
jetzt zuletzt haben es gehört die abas
holocaust äußerungen zunächst
widersprochen gelassen mangelt ist ihnen
da gelegentlich an einem richtigen
reflex nein und ich will ausdrücklich
sagen dass es mir sehr wichtig war sehr
schnell die notwendige aussage zu machen
was die äußerung von herrn abbas
betrifft das hab ich scharf kritisiert
und ich habe da für viele sehr wichtige
rückmeldung gute rückmeldung aus israel
bekommen aber ich bin ganz klar sagen
wir sind in einer zeit in der viele sehr
aufgeregt sind und ich zähle nicht zu
diesen und will es auch nicht sein
nach unserem gespräch treffen sie gleich
im anschluss den ukrainischen
regierungschef wie erklären sie ihm
eigentlich ihren begriff der besonnenen
waffenlieferungen was sind besonnene
waffenlieferungen wenn ein so
übermächtige aggressiver abgewehrt
werden muss deutschland hat unter meiner
führung entschieden dass wir überhaupt
waffen die ukraine liefern das war ein
bruch mit regeln die wir viele
jahrzehnte anders hatten wir haben
entschieden die bundeswehr aufzurüsten
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass es ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr von
100 milliarden euro gibt und wir liefern
nicht sicher ob das wort besonnen wir
liefern sehr effiziente sehr wirksame
waffen immer abgestimmt mit unseren
franken und verbündeten und die usa
großbritannien deutschland liefern zb
mehrfach raketenwerfer aber keine von
uns alleine wir haben unsere sehr
weitreichenden effektiven h
panzerhaubitzen dorthin geliefert
zusammen mit dem niederländer und so
sind alle entscheidungen gut abgewogen
und das will ich ausdrücklich sagen dazu
stehe ich es wird keine deutschen
alleingänge
die außenminister hatten rim hat ja
betont die ukraine so lange zu
unterstützen wie nötig sie haben dass
auch sie haben da zugestimmt was aber
wenn die mehrheiten der zustimmung hier
im land sich verändern in österreich
erleben wir jetzt schon dass 40 prozent
der menschen gegen eine verringerung der
sanktionen sind vielleicht spricht ja
die besonnene reaktion über die wir eben
gesprochen dafür dass die zustimmung in
deutschland erhalten bleiben so
der bundeskanzler danke ihnen für das
gespräch
für sie ja auch bewegten tag schöner und
das war unser sommerinterview mit dem
bundeskanzler das letzte in unserer
sommerserie
2022 und ich freue mich sie am kommenden
sonntag wieder bei berlin direkt
begrüßen zu dürfen ihnen noch einen
schönen abend sondern eine gute woche
[Musik]